good morning John you and I have been
making videos for over eight years now
over 1200 videos on this channel alone
enough four minute videos to keep a
person busy four days without sleeping
in that time I've told the whole world
everyone who will listen some of my
deepest fears and most embarrassing
moment I mean I've experienced some of
my most embarrassing moments on this
YouTube channel there's not a lot about
me left that isn't public it's to the
point where I would have a really hard
time coming up with the two truths and a
lie that I could catch anybody on
because all of the interesting things
about me you know it's got very little
left this is not a complaint I like it
this way being is open with the world
also makes you think about the secrets
you do keep those things do exist
I don't think there's anything weird
about that I don't think anyone on
either side of this situation thinks
that I should share everything about
everything about myself what is weird is
what I'm feeling something when I'm
excited or frustrated or angry and I
can't talk about that because I can't
tell you why other because of contracts
or responsibilities or strategies even I
don't know you know this and John I'm
not talking to you now I'm talking to
nerdfighteria you're really important in
my life it feels really weird it feels
wrong for important things to happen in
my life and to not talk about it whether
it's on a video or on Twitter or tumblr
or Facebook I'm not good at faking stuff
I can't suddenly get excited about
something that I've been doing for six
months just because now it's public I've
been excited that whole time I can't
pack that all into one announcement
video so what I'm super excited or
frustrated or angry about something I
can't talk about it that makes me feel
weird it makes me feel like a lie being
honest here honest about my lying things
like scishow kids and Krash first kids
which we've been working on for months
getting funding together and defining
them and doing character development and
hiring people who are amazing to do all
this great and amazing work and we
weren't allowed to talk about any of it
all that enthusiasm was so annoyingly
private but those things are real now
and I'm still excited about them at have
an extend about them for so long so if
there are kids in your life or their
parents who have kids in your life
please tell them because if people don't
watch it we can't keep making it right
now we've got two things that I'm very
excited about that I cannot tell you
about and I am just so fresh it's not
like new Hoodie designs or video ideas
or something like that it's big stuff
but you're not gonna guess but I concur
egde you to try and I feel like a phony
for being excited and not being able to
tell you on one of those things will be
announced early next week I'll be doing
a reddit AMA about it on Monday the
other will be announced a week after
that if all goes according to plan
LA Brothers has always been about
honesty and authenticity just being who
you are in huge field talking about
things that are happening hopefully in
interesting ways that are entertaining
or thought-provoking or whatever but
does this cover what we're doing with
scishow at crash course and VidCon and
dftba all these things has grown had
less freedom to talk about them because
there's just more complicated
infrastructure on top of it I'm so happy
to be working on big complicated
projects with talented people but
sometimes I just wish I could take
everyone along for the ride you know
been a long time I'm not used to living
that kind of private life anymore
especially with my work stuff I feel
like that stuff should be public it
feels wrong but I don't have any choice
and I don't know if it's better for me
to talk about this or not because now
you know that I'm keeping stuff from you
where the before you just could sort of
infer it and you're gonna be like what
what do you work what's the thing are
you making a new kind of ice cream are
you gonna be an astronaut no neither of
those things but again I encourage you
to guess in the comments because maybe
you'll give me good ideas for things to
do in the future anyway I'm very excited
and I can't say why you'll find out next
week and then the week after that it'll
be cool I'm excited to share them with
you then and I'm excited to continue
sharing my whole freakin life with you
in the future for a very long long time
John I'll see you on Tuesday
you
[Music]